[Música]
Hola Muy Bienvenidos a directo cop 27 el
espacio en el que les contamos lo más
relevante de todo lo que ha sucedido y
que está sucediendo en la Cumbre
climática de la ONU que Avanza en Egipto
y la gran pregunta que rodea al
encuentro es si logrará tener las
decisiones finales listas para mañana
cuando en teoría deberían acabar las
negociaciones pero todo apunta a que
esta meta es muy difícil de lograr vamos
ahora a sham and Shake con nuestra
enviada especial María Clara Calle María
Clara contanos Qué es lo que está
pasando
en un punto decisivo de la Copa 27
porque en teoría estamos a menos de 48
horas de terminar las discusiones de la
Cumbre climática aquí en charmershake
Egipto y todavía no hay avances notorios
en los temas más difíciles y que más han
dividido a los países como adaptación
mitigación finanzas y también perdidas y
daños que ha sido por supuesto el gran
tema en discusión para hablar de esto
nos acompaña Fernanda de carvalho ella
es directora de políticas de clima y
energía de WWE F Fernanda Gracias por
estar con nosotros y en este momento las
grandes divisiones se refieren a
mitigación y a pérdidas y daños
explíquenos por favor muy brevemente En
qué consiste esto y en qué van las
negociaciones
sí Ok entonces mitigación son las
discusiones sobre cómo disminuir las
emisiones y hay un programa en discusión
que este programa fue creado en Glasgow
y de aquí Tienen que salir una decisión
que explique cómo Esto va a funcionar
para 20-30 porque la verdad de que la
cena desees las los compromisos
nacionales no están fuertes lo
suficiente para para asegurar el aumento
la temperatura global del calentamiento
global en 1.5 grados entonces Esta es
una gran discusión para salir este
programa y la otra es de pérdidas y
daños que es compensaciones a los países
por impactos cuando este es impactos no
pueden ser mitigados o no hay más
adaptación posible por ejemplo cuando el
nivel del océano
aumenta mucho por ejemplo
terras son sumergidas territorios
subsumidos esto es pérdida ciudadanos
Entonces está en discusión aquí en esta
convención la creación de un fondo Para
apoyar a los países menos desarrollados
en esas situaciones de pérdidas de daños
y porque los países más desarrollados se
están oponiendo a la creación de este
mecanismo porque es una obligación de
más plata que es plata nuevas son son
presupuestos adicionales a los que
prometen es muy difícil lograr
compromisos de financiación en tiempos
de crisis hay una crisis de alimentos
hay una crisis de de combustibles
fósiles con la guerra en Rusia hay
inflación en estos países Entonces es
difícil ahora lo lograron compromiso de
más presupuestos públicos para una cosa
que puede ser enorme no se sabe tampoco
Cuánto es necesario para los enemages
pérdidas y daños bueno y en 2015 se
pactó el acuerdo de París que dijo que
el mundo necesitaba limitar el
calentamiento global en dos grados
centígrados Respecto a los niveles
preindustriales y que ojalá esto se
limitará en 1.5 desde desde las eras
preindustriales ya ha habido un
calentamiento de
1,1%. y ya vemos las catástrofes como
las inundaciones en Pakistán y también
la hambruna en el cuerno de África o la
sequías y las olas de calor en Europa
Estados Unidos Asia y África
Esto hace dudar que la meta del 1.5
grados centígrados este difícil de
alcanzar Usted cree que se puede
alcanzar esa meta en esta Cup seguirá
viva esa meta y si no sigue viva Cuáles
serían las consecuencias yo creo que
puedes seguir viva si hay decisiones
fuertes si hay una decisión de capa que
es la decisión política que Dónde están
las directrices políticas y emocionales
al sector privado si habla de 1.5 porque
él ipcc el panel de científicos que
asesor esta convención ha dicho que hay
soluciones y las soluciones son cosas
efectivas entonces lo que estamos
dependiendo es de voluntad política es
de muchos de esos pedazos de esas pesas
que tienen que se juntar para que
podemos para que podamos mantener 1.5
Cómo estamos ahora está difícil decir
que esta Cup va a mantener 1. pero
también uno como 48 horas como dijiste
es poco tiempo Pero también es tiempo
suficiente para que la voluntad política
venga Esto es lo que queremos ver de los
líderes aquí horas determinantes
entonces para mirar la voluntad política
y alcanzar la limitación del
calentamiento global Gracias Fernanda
por estar con nosotros y sigan ustedes
con más Gracias María Clara por otro
completísimo reporte desde Egipto
finalizamos otra emisión de directo con
27 a nuestra audiencia le invitamos por
supuesto a seguir conectados con Franz
24 para conocer todo lo que está
ocurriendo en la Cumbre climática de la
ONU que ya se encuentra en su tramo
final sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]